marks I know you're very very close to a
former president Trump when you hear
Alex describing the reality as some
people see it but Trump didn't see it at
the time the factors they stood that he
lost the election but Trump believed
that he won how does that make you feel
how does that make you feel as a
supporter of trump
well what's really important is for us
to truly examine
um why is it that 50 plus percent of the
American Republican party uh and the
supporters of President Trump still
believe also that he too lost uh won the
election that he actually won the
election but but but but better than
that we need to be discussing why is it
that uh Joe Biden's doj has been used uh
and this latest indictment has been used
as a distraction from the Joe Biden
bribery scheme a scam that that's what's
really should be the topic president
Trump isn't guilty uh of the January 6
uh that he's been falsely accused of I
was there I was a speaker I was there in
the ground he's clearly not guilty but
yet this is uh the weaponization of the
Department of Justice led by Joe Biden
and his cronies to attack the leading
candidate for the Republican nomination
and according to the latest poll uh if
the elections were held today a head-on
match between Joe Biden that President
Trump would come out ahead uh President
Biden yes
using this uh as a way to create a
Banana Republican out of the greatest
nation in the world we call the United
States Pastor Mark both things are
possible uh there is possible uh
corruption obviously within both sides
here uh both sides can be tried it is
Trump that has received the third
indictment and you talked there about
the weaponization of the justice system
we were just hearing from Alan
dershowitz that he believes it's been
weaponized on both sides I will come
back to you but I want a crossover to
David K Johnston on this idea then this
weaponization do you think that it's
pure water baptism to say that this is a
sort of uh a construct to distract away
from Biden issues
oh that's exactly what's going on here
uh first of all uh under the law you
can't turn a deaf ear just as you can't
turn a blind eye and when the Attorney
General the United States appointed by
Donald Trump when the White House
Council appointed by Donald Trump and a
whole lot of other people appointed by
Donald Trump tell him you lost the
election uh if he wants to engage in a
fantasy belief that's not a defense in a
criminal case the law about that is
eminently clear and all of the testimony
that's going to be damaging to Donald
Trump is going to come from Republicans
who he either appointed or brought in to
give him advice vice president Mike
Pence is going to be the star witness in
this case Mark Meadows Donald Trump's
chief of staff is going to be a witness
in this case there's not a single person
who's a Democrat who's like likely to be
called as a witness in this case because
the facts were all taking place in front
of other Republicans
I'll come back to you Alex hearing this
it feels like what we're going to be
seeing argued about in court is almost
the basis of what constitutes reality
um and that's going to be very tough
because Trump has set up a universe in
which he has a reality his supporters
follow that reality and then there is a
reality that others see and some would
argue that it's the Liberals that said
or Biden sees it
um it's going to be an interesting case
to watch as a documentarian surely
yeah absolutely I mean you know the idea
that we're debating reality is pretty
trumpian in a sense right I mean your
your guest before the pastor just
mentioned he was there on the 6th of
January and I mean to say that he
doesn't think the president time was
responsible I mean did he not see what I
saw which is one of Trump's own
supporters being crushed to death on the
steps of the capital I mean that's what
the rhetoric led to and then to start
talking about Biden and you know that
that's not the point the point here is
that Donald Trump was utterly
irresponsible and dangerous you know he
is a benighted individual and yes you
know I mean just to quote Bill Barr he
said that Trump was detached from
reality and of course that's not a
defense in uh in any Court proceedings
you know he's a 70 mid 70 year old man
knew exactly what he was doing and yet
didn't care and then obviously all the
evidence that came out in the January 6
committee hearings where he just kept
going and was watching the events on
January 6 on TV and refusing to
intervene until the last minute and even
then in a hard part of the manner I mean
he said on the stage we need to fight
like hell and then you know in the
preceding months he was maintaining that
position as president
Pastor Mark a chance to respond to that
because yes Pastor you did say that you
were there January 6th and Alex here was
talking about dangerous rhetoric
um and where it leads to in terms of the
actual sort of activity if we could call
it that that we saw on January the 6th
and then what do you make of the
rhetoric of likening the current justice
system and the federal government to the
Nazi party
well again as I said earlier uh you know
this is the weaponization of the
Department of Justice uh Joe Biden's
weaponization of against the leading
candidate for president of the United
States of America what is a fantasy uh
that we're not we should excuse me what
is not a fantasy um is uh Hunter Biden's
laptop what's not a fantasy is the
sitting president of the United States
of America
um took bribes right we approved the
evidence is coming out we're talking
about some rhetoric about uh that that
could be a Mis uh Mis described uh by uh
the liberal f as Donald Trump leading a
initiative to destroy January 6th but
the reality is the fact is Joe Biden is
a criminal and he is the sitting
president of the United States of
America and we are talking about Donald
Trump being indicted come on I mean
a foreign agent of another government
it's not a conspiracy it's fact right
and yet we're still talking about a
candidate the timing of it is ridiculous
the fact that this indictment is coming
out as soon as we getting close to uh
the truth about Joe Biden but yet people
are going to sleep on the fact that
doj is leading this investigation come
on now we've given you we've given you
the platform smart food by this to put
across that point of view and to get it
out there and those allegations and
innocent till proven guilty on all sides
in this at the moment
um I do think the public can see though
when asked about Trump and people
immediately point at Biden it does look
like distraction look David I want to
give you the last word on this and talk
about the future for the uh for Trump's
presidency but for the Republican party
where could you see it going from here
well the Republican party was warned 50
years ago that it had to get up with the
times because the demographics in
America were changing and it hasn't
changed unfortunately the Republicans
who used to call themselves The Party of
Law and Order want to defund the FBI
they have come out against all sorts of
law enforcement matters they're
supporting Donald Trump a man who
applied 12 and 13 year old children with
liquor limousines and hotel rooms
because they had money to gamble in his
casinos and I I bet the pastor doesn't
know that in one of his books Donald
spends six pages denouncing Christians
as fools idiots and Schmucks says he has
never once asked God what I do know is
that Donald Trump is the greatest
president that we've had in our lifetime
for Christians that I do know I can't
talk about what Donald Trump did
yesterday I can tell you
today is free indeed I can't speak about
what he did years ago I can talk about
what he done today thank God there's a
speech called Amazing Grace how sweet
I'm found
well Donald was President he declared
that his life philosophy is Revenge no
one who's a Christian can have Revenge
the life philosophy there's videotaping
him the president uh In Our Lifetime the
fact that he he signed the executive
order
the fact that he's going out the trade
in the public school system never cut
anyone off on a show before but I'm
close to doing it and I know you're just
you're taking every inch that you can
get but please let David finish this
point okay thank you while he was
president at the last National Prayer
Breakfast Donald Trump once again
declared that he that revenge is his
philosophy which no Christian believes
uh Donald Trump's conduct here is going
to be either proven or not proven in a
court of law if Joe Biden has committed
crimes and so far there's zero evidence
in this exactly zero just claims then he
should be also pursued and I'm confident
that he will be but the issue on the
floor now is the indictment of Donald
Trump for his failed effort to overthrow
the government of the United States and
the evidence against him is going to
come from his own people it's going to
be his own vice president among others
who are going to testify to what he did
thank you gentlemen all of you it's been
fascinating Alex was sitting there
quietly documenting this we do
appreciate your insights as well and
pasta as well as uh David thanks so much